hey everyone welcome to gamespot
universes nerding out my name's Randy
I've got Tony here with me and today
we're gonna be chatting about the latest
episode of agents of shield called laka
laka let's talk about it so Tony we
learned quite a lot about the dark hold
blindly finally what would you actually
learn a lot about we just saw it so tell
me about it yeah so originally we just
saw a picture but now we saw when Lucy
and her husband Joe when they found it
in the basement one thing that I noticed
there in that that basement that cellar
there is a carnival poster Quentin
carnival that's actually the poster
that's that's at the carnival that
Johnny Blaze der riginal ghost writer
worked at easter eggs easter egg but has
nothing new with this so they find a
book they read it they look at it and
the interesting thing is when Joe looked
at it was in German when Lucy saw two
pages of text it was in English turned
out it was breeding them it was based on
the first language they learned so this
book is magical so ghost Lucy couldn't
touch it she couldn't touch it couldn't
touch it he was ticked off so what do we
know about this book what is it in the
comic books in a cot it's it's a the
book of sins it's evil it's it's got
dark thing we don't really know what she
wants to book for what they were trying
to do because you're doing it the
quantum particle stuff what they need to
do to with the book why did the book
turn them into go so that's something
that we still need to flush out to see
how it's going to be used and what is
the tie with ghost writer because why
can Robby ray is kill the ghost what is
his connection to the book so now Lucy
who can't touch the book needs uncle
Eli's help to actually read the book so
that she goes to the prison and then
agents of shield actually try and go
there with Robbie in tow and quake as
well and they have this whole sort of
big prison breakout sequence tell me
about that yeah so we get some some cool
jailhouse scenes and one of the things
like with with Daisy she can't use her
powers she's got the gaunt once again
because if she uses her powers her bones
are gonna shatter so we see some some
old-school fighting and you know she
trained with me so that was really cool
what I like about that is you know if
you have the powers at school to have
the powers but sometimes it's too easy
you know
seemed too easy you just zap someone so
she had to fight everything Robbie you
know he's already there getting Eli out
things pandemonium is chaos in the
prison but then he goes off to do his
own thing that's when Eli gets taken
it's a very selfish move to by Robbie
right basically screwed up the whole
mission I didn't help it he was had this
burning burning desire hahaha I gotta
kill a gang member did did you know he's
obsessed he wants vengeance okay so it
seemed like he was the last gang member
it that's what the dialogue Sam yeah cuz
he want to know who did this drive-by
shooting that shot him and his brother
put gabe in a wheelchair and then the
guy in jail you know he says I wasn't
there I was I've been in here and he's
like there's no one else left and
Robbie's holding when he was talking
with Daisy he's like you know if I kill
everyone that I could get rid of this
thing so if that's truth there's no
other gang members he kills that guy but
he's still ghost writer he's oh god he
walks out he's flaming there's obviously
a lot more to ghost rider story and I
think it's probably got something to do
with the book just move on to the next
big thing in this thing which is Jeffrey
mace the director of shield went on live
TV and said he was an inhuman it was a
pretty big deal he's was sort of
ignoring the advice to do something he
just blurted it out what do you think of
that yeah so senator nadir that she's we
know she hates Inhumans she's in that
humans first she's she is like nailing
you know she's ramming in tune with all
these questions and questioning
everything and then he's just like I'm
an inhuman and it was a big bombshell
people loved it he went up in the polls
you're all excited but then we see at
the end he's in a car with with the
senator hmm and you know she's she knows
some stuff she's likes like Oh shield
was working with quake she's wanted
who's this other flaming guy what are
you guys hiding I'm gonna leak this to
ABC News because that's what channel
cross yes and then so he's like well
what do you want so he's gonna make some
sort of deal with her but the fact that
they're so friendly in a car together
there's still that question can he be
trusted also be sure to check out some
CBS wonderful shows on CBS as well a
parent company to print some product
placement there as well but you
obviously don't trust Jeffrey mace who
seemed so clean-cut and aboveboard why
don't you trust him I don't I mean
for him to be in a car there with the
senator you know he well he doesn't know
how evil she is he knows she's against
in humans but why would they meet in a
car why wouldn't they talk on the phone
why wouldn't they meet you know in a
boardroom or whatever your conference
room so there's something up with her
and Coulson still not trusting him you
know when when they're under mission
he's like we don't know if we can trust
him he you know he says that he doesn't
want to tell him that they're going
after alighted they're going after the
dark hole book so Coulson knows him and
we know there's some tension from when
we first saw him in the second episode
there's there something going on there's
more to to Jeffrey and also when he
mentions the mission in Vienna Simmons
like you didn't really do that so he's
hiding something so final point we got
to make today and that is what is Lucy's
plan with the dog hold so now she has
uncle Eli you we end the episode with
Eli reading the book and having some
sort of revelatory sort of yeah look on
his face yeah what is our plan that's
that's a big question is we know she
wants a book she worse I'm assuming she
wants not be a ghost anymore no one
wants of vehicles no so because so we're
assuming she wants the book to fix that
but then she wants to finish what they
started so you know what what was their
whole plan I'm curious what was Eli's
part when he was brought in because he
didn't get turned into a ghost like the
others and is he gonna be infected if
he's touching the book to read it to
help her is he gonna become a ghost or
is something else why did it become
ghosts you know what was the part of the
accelerator exploded in her face you
know so there's dirt that's something
one of the wait and see there's a lot
more to come and that's it for our
nerding out on this latest episode of
agents of shield for more and shield and
all the other shows that you love check
out gamespot universe
you